من جهته قال رئيس الوزراء البريطاني ريشي
سوناك قال ان سلاح الجو الملكي نفذ ضربات
موجهه استهدفت منشات عسكريه يستخدمها
الحوثيون في اليمن واضاف سوناك في بيان ان
المملكه المتحده اتخذت اجراءات محدوده
وضروريه ومتناسب للدفاع عن النفس لاضعاف
القدرات العسكريه للحوثيين وحمايه الشحن
العالمي سوناك اضاف ان المملكه المتحده
ستدافع دوما عن حريه الملاحه وتدفق
التجاره
الى ذلك قال وزير الدوله البريطاني لشؤون
الدفاع جوان شابس ان طائرات التايفون نفذت
ضربات دقيقه على هدفين عسكريين للحوثيين
الى جانب القوات الامريكيه واضاف وزير
الدوله البريطاني لشؤون الدفاع جران شابس
في تغريده على منصه اكس لقد اصبح التهديد
الذي تتعرض له ارواح الابرياء والتجاره
العالميه كبيرا جدا لدرجه ان هذا الاجراء
لم يكن ضروريا فحسب بحسب م قال
بل كان من الواجب حمايه والسفن وحريه
الملاحه